perso j'aime bien cette couleur jusqu'au
samsung vraiment vraiment bien bossé
ce bleu comme ça est vraiment juste
magnifique avec ceux dont anvers triple
capteur photo c'est vraiment une bonne
idée sur un smartphone qui globalement
dans milieu de gamme dresse pas cher on
trouve
[Musique]
j'ai une excellente nouvelle ça fait
plusieurs jours que vous me parlez du
samsung galaxy à 7 à tester et j'ai
aussi beaucoup de demandes pour tester
le galaxy j-6 avec la chance ils sont
arrivés tous les deux ce matin
fraîchement par transporteur ça c'est
plutôt cool donc aujourd'hui prg
aujourd'hui on va commencer par le n 7
on va boxer on regarde un peu plus
offert une première prise en main voir
un petit peu ce qui est dit j'ai déjà
rencontré je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez lorsque j'étais il ya quelques
jours les quelques jours il ya quelques
semaines sur un showroom samsung à paris
c'était franchement hyper hyper qu'on le
jour de son annonce
j'ai pu prendre en main le tester alors
regardez un peu ce qu'ils disaient et je
vous ai fait une vidéo déjà quelques
temps mais maintenant on va faire deux
choses on va donc leur box aujourd'hui
pays si quelques jours lorsque j'aurai
bien prise en main que j'aurais bien
tester je me sentirai mon test complet
pour vous dire ce que je pense de ce
galaxy à sept sa ses premiers points
deuxième point comme je vous le dis vous
avez été super nombreux rires ouais là
qu'est il ya des smartphones tout hyper
cher il ya tout mais on est aussi
intéressé par le gie 6 le gie si c'est
ce que tu peux nous en parler nous dire
ce que tu en penses il est bien pas bien
et gna gna gna gna avec grand plaisir
bien sûr vous demandez je m'exécute
laquelle se serait plaint tout cas en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je
vais le tester
et puis on en reparlera parce que ça
avec les smartphones d'entrée de gamme
de samsung
il ya assez peu de contenu dessus donc
si je peux vous faire plaisir
c'est avec grand grand grand plaisir et
puis n'oubliez pas et c'est ce que je
vous disais l'autre jour reçu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones
beaucoup de nouveautés il ya pas mal de
choses à tester donc bah je vous invite
à faire une seule chose c'est bien sûr
vous abonner vous restez connectés comme
ça on va reparler tout ça il ya plein de
choses hyper cool et dire voilà donc la
boîte duroux faire tomber ça commence
bien voilà donc la boîte du samsung
galaxy à 7 de 2018 c'est bien marqué ici
hyper sort de toute façon dans les
smartphone milieu de gamme samsung fait
hyper sobre et vous réserve des
packagings de fou pour les smartphones
haut de gamme quoique quoiqu'un j'aime
beaucoup la couleur du gie 6 août non
vraiment c'est aussi un très très bel
effort de faire un truc très sympa voilà
donc ça on en parle d'une prochaine
forte
alaxia 7 alors on ouvre donc voilà la
bête
voilà le smartphone on va le regarder
d'ici quelques instants
ce qu'on a tout de suite déjà c'est le
trip module photo vous allez voir à ces
trucs qui est vraiment intéressant alors
dans la boîte j'imagine que ça va être
assez sommaire vu qu'on est quand même
sur du milieu de gamme
alors comment ça ne vient pas ici petit
dock prise en main on doit avant les
garanties on doit avoir tout ça fait ça
termes de garanties très simple on a le
bloc de charge qui juste là on a on a
qu'est ce qu'on a on a le chargeur alors
vous êtes un peu déçu parce que je
voulais déjà dit c'est du micro usb il
n'ya pas d'usb type c'est là dessus
j'imagine que c'est pour des coups pour
sortir un smartphone pas trop cher je
pense on a néanmoins des petits
écouteurs ça c'est cool qui les
écouteurs samsung à l'intérieur et bonne
nouvelle
on voit ici la prise jack donc ça veut
dire qu'on a une prise jack sur la bête
très très bonne nouvelle et je crois que
c'est à peu près tout l'intérieur
vous avez de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de
cartes sim ici vous avez de quoi changer
votre petite oreillette pas comment on
appelle ça directement sur le casque
donc ça c'est cool voyez ça c'est un
boxing efficace pas fronde ouvrons ce
hors tac tac voilà ses bisous à bientôt
de chaud on s'en arrête pas là à
rassurer vos bien évidemment le
smartphone est là on va commencer par
ouvrir ça
on va commencer par ouvrir ça on va
l'allumer on va le configurer on va
commencer à tester un peu voir les
premières fonctionnalités et puis on
arrêtera là j'adore l'ouverture avec ces
bruits oh là là quelle qui passe chaque
fois qu'elle kiffe
est-ce qu'il est pas cool mon métier la
première chose à faire on va tout de
suite enlevé ça qui le défigure un petit
peu voilà ce qui est vraiment cool en
termes de design c'est le triple module
photo positionner ici sur le côté c'est
la toute première fois que ça me saoule
nous sort un triple module photo et il
le fait sur un smartphone milieu de
gamme ça franchement c'est hyper cool
logo samsung ici et surtout ce que vous
voyez ces cas pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales qu'on avait avant
ici sur les smartphones samsung
il y en a plus ça c'est cool ça veut
donc dire que le capteur d'empreintes
digitales
il a switché ici sur le côté un peu
comme ce qu'on peut retrouver chez sony
donc vous tenez votre smartphone vous
posez votre pouce sur le côté comme ça
vous déverrouillez la position est assez
simple finalement
on la trouve assez facilement je vais le
tester de l'allumer je vais vous dire
mais bon comme ça en tout cas c'est à
d'être assez cool
heil mais tu n'aimes up qui scotche sur
les côtés il est protégé de tous les
côtés rapide prise en main ce smartphone
du point de vue design vous avez un dos
en verre un dos en verre j'adore cette
couleur je trouve vraiment très jolie
par contre ce que je vais lui reprocher
tout de suite ce que je vois
immédiatement sur les traces de doigts
après c'est pas normal
voilà c'est un doux envers forcément ça
laisse des traces de doigts peut pas
tout avoir ce qui est sympa ce design
avec des bords légèrement arrondi je
trouve ça assez sympa le fait d'avoir le
bouton ici avec le capteur d'empreintes
digitales
alors je vais vous montrer pour
déverrouiller c'est assez rigolo ici les
boutons de volume en bas vous avez votre
prise jack port micro usb
ici un haut parleur mono petit lim petit
coin micro qui est juste là d'un côté
vous avez si votre tiroir de cartes sim
alors ce qui est sympa là dessus si vous
avez une double signe plus une carte
micro sd vous pouvez étendre jusqu'à 512
giga au dessus petit coin pour micro et
puis voilà on a fait un peu le tour de
la bête d'un point de vue design là
dessus et je vous dis vraiment
l'originalité de ce galaxy s est
sévèrement son triple module photo ici
c'est son capteur d'empreintes digitales
sur le côté ça c'est une première fois
que samsung met ça dans un smartphone
c'est plutôt cool je positionne j'appuie
jeunesse mon doigt ça brasse est assez
rapide ça c'est rapide ça me semble un
peu moins rapide qu'un capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière
je dirais vraiment la longue si j'ai des
difficultés ou non alors au niveau
l'écran vous avez bien évidemment un
écran super amoled une diagonale de 6
pouces une résolution de 2220 par 1080
pixels c'est du fnj plus à 400 ppp
luminosité pousser à fond vraiment bien
vraiment bien je vois tous les côtés je
vais d'un côté de l'autre ça marche
extrêmement bien leur après les dalles
samsung fonctionne vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien là dessus au niveau de la
partie photo dans donc un triple
capteurs capteur principal de 24
mégapixels akin ouverture de f
1.7 donc lumineux autofocus à détection
de phase
vous avez un capteur grand-angle de 5
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.4
qui va surtout servir pour le mode
portrait et un autre à 8 mégapixels
c'est un ultra grand angle 120°
ouverture de f 2.2 s'en va le tester sa
r&d vraiment bien et à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de 24 mégapixels qu'une
ouverture de f 2.0
là je suis sur le mode photo un petit
peu classique et la semelle
ultra-grand-angle s'est légèrement
arrondi ça déforme un petit peu après
c'est normal c'est du très grand-angle
hyper time lapse arm moggi ralenti
optimisation scène automatique mise au
point direct beauté pro panorama fin il
ya pas mal de choses à faire au niveau
perf
on verra ce que ça donne on a un exil
aux 7885 cadencé jusqu'à 2 2 giga hertz
4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
extensible à versailles carte micro sd
ici jusqu'à 512 giga on a une batterie
de trois mille trois cent millions
terreur donc on verra aussi l'autonomie
on a du bluetooth 5.0 on a une
certification ip68 donc c'est un
smartphone qui étanche
on va éviter de l'occident la flotte
mais en tout cas ces rencontres de haut
il n'est pas trop grave problème il
tourne sous android
huit auraient au mont classique
surcouche expérience 8 donc on va voir
ce que ça dit lors des phases de test
mais en tout cas comme ça je trouve cool
moi perso j'aime bien cette couleur
jusqu'au samsung vraiment vraiment bien
bossé
ce bleu comme ça est vraiment juste
magnifique avec ce dos en verre triple
capteur photo c'est vraiment une bonne
idée sur un smartphone qui globalement
dans mille il viendrait ce pas cher on
trouve à 349 euros et voir un peu moins
cher d'ailleurs si vous intéresse je
vous mets un lien en bas dans la
description
bon voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
sur ce samsung galaxy ace est de 2
18 laissez moi un petit peu de temps de
le prendre en main de vous dire ce que
j'en pense comment je le trouvais ce que
les photos sont bien j'ai vraiment ça le
focus sur les photos parce que là dessus
on va vraiment c'est ce triple module
photo qui est vraiment mis en avant par
samsung surtout sur un smartphone
à ce prix là je pense qu'on peut avoir
des résultats très intéressants ont
regardé un peu par rapport à la
concurrence comment ils se positionnent
est ce qu'au final ce galaxy à 7 est un
bon choix en tout cas très très
rapidement comme ça je peux déjà vous
dire les points positifs
je trouve que la prise en main est bien
le format est bien le capteur
d'empreintes digitales son côté c'est
pas mal ça déverrouille assez rapidement
c'est assez réactif l'écran et hop les
écrans samsung on les connaît ils sont
toujours très très très bien super
amoled 6 pouces c'est très bien après ce
qu'il faut pas craindre là dessus c'est
d'avoir à débord qui sont un peu épais
sur le haut un peu épais sur le bas des
bordures noires sur le côté ce qui est
sympa malgré tout c'est le fait d'avoir
ces petits coins arrondis ici je trouve
que c'est pas mal ça gâche pas le
plaisir
il ya un vrai bon boulot qui a été fait
là dessus c'est pas un smartphone cheap
loin de là je te conseille vraiment en
tout cas comme ça un très très beau
milieu de gamme
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire merci à vous
d'être toujours là nombreuses nombreux
je vous invite à aller voir la vidéo
suivante je fais plein de vidéos sur les
smartphones test smartphone comment
choisir votre smartphone lequel il ya
plein plein plein de vidéos ça peut vous
aider
donc n'hésitez pas à aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil sur la playlist d'ici
là soyez ça je vous embrasse
puis rester connecté parce qu'on va en
parler à bientôt ciao